qu'il faut être très attentif aux plus
modestes à ceux qui parfois sur les plus
éloignés d'une forme de compréhension et
de pédagogie et je le dire avec le plus
grand respect c'est vers cela qu'il va
falloir aller pour leur dire que se
vacciner parce que se vacciner c'est pas
se protéger soi uniquement c'est se
protéger collectivement c'est donc un
acte de solidarité collective
j'entendais le président lors de son
intervention dans la deuxième partie
nous nous parler du du futur mais son
bilan il est quand même assez mitigé
regardez en termes de dépenses publiques
et je parle en éco guides on avait fait
plus 80 milliards une dette à 2200
milliards en matière migratoire et on
s'apprête sans doute malheureusement à
cause de la situation en afghanistan
avoir une deuxième vague migratoire
échec aussi en matière de grandes
réformes parler des retraites et la
réforme sur la dépendance et on a vu que
cette réforme était indispensable avec
la pandémie sur nos aînés mais il a dit
vouloir faire tout ça est ce que c'est
un président candidat que vous avez
entendu vous donne ce soir un candidat
d'un candidat mais il a dit que le bilan
n'était qu'un socle alors le socle ut3